nearly 70 years ago a couple called
George and Marjorie set sail for London
bringing eight of their nine children
with them from the Caribbean within a
few years they had a tenth that was me
George
Marjorie and their kids mostly did well
as will the four hundred million or so
others who will cross the border to live
and work during my lifetime but for many
like the 39 migrants who died fighting
for air in a refrigerated container
there is no happy ending nobody should
die that way and the blame has to be
laid at the door of the smugglers who
took their money and then left them to
perish but here's a brutal truth the 39
weren't starving refugees like George
and Marjorie they're thought to be
economic migrants who most of us would
not have expressed much compassion for
if they'd lived and been caught our
immigration system is becoming an
organized hypocrisy that rewards the
wealthy and the devious punishes those
who wait their turn and risks the lives
of the innocent and the naive we should
stop shedding crocodile tears and
urgently divides a new fair rational
system of immigration but ceases putting
people in peril Trevor I agree with much
of what you say it does seem that the
system does not work at all and what we
saw last week actually was was
devastating whether they were economic
migrants or whether they were as eylem
seekers these were young people in the
main who'd left there who were in the
paying tens of thousands of pounds to
criminal gangs to die in a lorry in a
refrigerated lorry and I didn't know how
anyone's heart couldn't break for them
whether they came from wealthy
backgrounds or not they died the most
horrible death at the hands of criminal
is criminals
having said that you're right we need to
have a system that works and clearly if
27,000 people were arrested and I think
for
illegally entering the UK last year and
93 percent of Africans say that African
migrants said they experienced danger as
they tried to leave their countries in
order to seek better life
it is beholden on this country to have
some sort of system that doesn't put
people's lives at risk we've got a
system there's a European and what's
interesting here is that Europe has gone
from being the continent from which you
went off and you explored the rest of
the world it is now the destination
continent and people are coming from all
over the world and we understand why we
enjoy a relatively good lifestyle but we
have a system across the whole of Europe
which is the treaties whereby the first
country that you arrive in when you come
so whether it be Greece whether it be
Italy wherever it's wherever you land
you then seek asylum in that country and
that will stand that will stop people
that clinging to the bottom of lawyers
hiding in lawyers or whatever else it
might be for whatever reason these
people then decide that they want to
keep on currently no route for
low-skilled migrants from places like
Vietnam to lawfully come to a country
like the UK to work there is no so it's
not like they're jumping the queue there
is no queue and I that's my
interpretation of what you're saying
show that we need a system that does
allow people because we need those jobs
they're doing jobs in our economy
they're not coming to live on benefits
they are working in nail parlors and in
agriculture and the point is we need a
functional system that acknowledges we
need this migrant labor it performs an
important role economically in as long
as it's coming by refusing to provide a
leaf legal room we are being complete
what you're saying is theoretically true
therefore and that's where I would like
it to be it isn't actually entirely true
and this is why you get this kind of
tragedy that actually there are routes
by which low paid people can come here
but the way that the system works is not
organized it's not transparent because
people can be convinced in Vietnam or
sub-saharan Africa but they will come
and they will get all sorts of
privileges they they couldn't get the
Canadians which is a system
favor have very clear roots you can be
brought in on high paying high skilled
visa you can be brought in to do some
low paid jobs and there are quotas and
then they are ruthless about enforcing
the exclusions we don't do either of
those two things we're not clear about
who's allowed to come and then we're
pretty poor at enforcing the border and
that's why we get into this situation
where people think well you know oh my
cousin got in so I will be able to get
in and they end up in the back of these
trucks and by the way they found twelve
people in a car park in near antwerp
yesterday that's not on the front pages
because they were alive my problem is
that what's happening is the policy is
being driven by headlines and compassion
when we need some rationality everything
you're saying there's a reason it's not
that our policymakers just didn't think
to make a functional policy the whole
area of policy around immigration has
been driven by this race to the bottom
on xenophobia and racism and no
politician wants to be seen to be doing
what we need want to come in a lawful
because I'm not this racist xenophobic
narrative because I just don't think
that's right but if you talk you talk
about the business side of this and
actually Vietnamese people being
smuggled here they've made smugglers 234
million pounds in a year alone so it is
huge business for these smugglers so
whatever policy you seek to have or not
have what you need to be making sure is
that you're you're plugging the holes so
when you've got that amount of smugglers
they're not going to stop anytime soon
if they're making hundreds of millions
of pounds bringing people over and I
matter what system you've got in the
land those smugglers are still going to
be trying to get their way around it
because that is their revenue stream
you're going to have businesses that try
and work really hard to to attract these
people but
they compare them way below what they
need to pay them you're gonna have
consumers who like to get their nails
done but instead of paying fair to quit
over there they need to pay their now
decide to pay 20 quid over there to the
Vietnamese people so there's a whole
it's not just about the route in it's
about stopping the mismanagement and
extend but it's where this is where I do
agree with that for there needs to be a
set of legal routes that are understood
and clear and we don't have that and I
have to tell you the biggest surprise
for me at the moment is that I agree
with a conservative Home Secretary
here's what Preeti Patel has to say
because she wants to have a much more
rational system and she's beginning to
think clearly about it I think for the
first time it is clear that we and all
our partners must enhance our response
all areas of government have a role to
play whether it's in strengthening our
borders and eliminating the pull factors
in this country or addressing many of
the root causes to suppress the demand
of illegal migration what I like about
that is who's got number one thing put
more money and help into the country to
where people are coming from so there's
less demand and secondly be clear about
what the channels to come are to address
central point which is if there are
hundreds of millions of pounds on the
table just put in your new post they're
not going to fold their tent and go away
you've not addressed because there's
demand Nick they're getting that money
because there is demand to do to come
through the illegal room if there were
more proper legal routes two things
would happen one is there'd be less
demand for the smugglers and secondly we
would have the moral right to enforce
exclusion in a way we don't do at the
moment we hear from one of the people
who had this experience men this is a
Vietnamese man who came to the UK who
was expressing his feelings about what
he heard happened in that lorry in Essex
I know you're not very good Ted the new
teddy bear come come
so you hear from him the level of
desperation that he knew he was taking a
rest his life was in danger but he felt
that he had no choice because there was
no other way he could make that journey
and and make the money he needed to make
to survive and this is exactly what
Trevor you're saying I think that I
agree with that people want to come they
don't want to come to commit crime or do
they want to work we need their labor we
we benefit from their labor so let's
create a rational system so that people
can come and work most these people want
to go back to their country they're not
coming here to stay here for generations
they have work to do and then they want
to leave and benefit from it and also
let them go it's one reason why last
wave of immigrants South Asians and so
on are the most hostile to immigration
because they they did it the fairway
they'd waited their turn and they hate
the cheating that's going on
and with our system encourages cheating
we'll have to park that conversation at
the border for now because we